speaking about relationships one of the
most
uh common traumas probably that people
are going to go through is heartbreak
right you're going to be in a
relationship that you imagine is going
to continue forever maybe when you're 18
or sometimes when you're 48
and
then it's going to stop have you thought
about the neuroscience of what's
happening during heartbreak
you know we did so i've done episodes of
our podcast on
love attachment and relationships
which is a fascinating literature mostly
from psychology but also bio biological
literature
and that's mostly about people's
orientation toward attachment so they're
just very quickly
there's the so-called secure attached
style this typically emerges in
childhood when there's a very
predictable care
um caregiver carry a relationship
between child and most often mother but
it can be father too or other caregiver
just so happens that the classic
experiments were done on mothers because
this was in the 1970s and there weren't
as many
reverse role rela you know homes etc
there were some but not as many as there
are now so
that's one style of attachment the
parent leaves the child gets a little
distraught but then can distract itself
doing other things or just simply do
other things because they have a high
degree of intrinsic knowledge not the
thought but intrinsic
calm the autonomic nervous system
doesn't feel any need to ramp up because
the mom returns then there's the
so-called insecure attachment styles and
they're a bunch of different ones but
those are the ones where
it's really stressful when the parent
leaves it's not clear they're going to
come back and when they come back it's
not clear that there's they're going to
re-establish the bond the child will
feel
supported et cetera
here's what's fascinating those same
neural circuits
are repurposed for romantic attachment
in adult life the same circuits which
shouldn't surprise us i mean why would
the brain throw away valuable circuitry
but this whole freudian notion that you
know childhood attachment styles map
onto adult attachment styles
that's real that's physiological now one
important point it's not one for one in
the sense that let's say you had a
secure attachment to your father let's
say it's a young a young girl and as a
baby and a young child she had a secure
attachment to her father and an insecure
attachment to her mother
in adulthood and let's say she's
heterosexual so in adulthood she prefers
men as romantic partners this girl grows
up and you might say well she had a good
relationship to her dad so she's going
to have a good secure attachment style
in her adult heterosexual relationships
ah often it's not the case they will
transplant or superimpose the insecure
attachment style to the to the mother on
to male relationships but have great
relationships to female friends for
instance so we have to be a little
careful to not map one for one that's
important so all of that is in us
and then you were talking about breakups
and we did an episode on grief and the
way that grief works in the brain and
nervous system is that there are three
sort of factors that are mapped in our
consciousness and our subconscious and
these are space
time and this notion of closeness which
is attachment space and time is very
simple it's where is the person that i
love and when will i see them next right
i mean if you have a relative that lives
overseas and you know they're alive
you're not going to grieve them you
might really miss them but you're not
going to grieve them the same way you
would if suddenly you get the note
unfortunately that they passed away
and then attachment is how close you are
to them like how critically you rely on
them for
internal
control and support and that doesn't
mean they have to be an immediate
caregiver it could just be like a really
good friend you call them mates over in
the uk right like a really good friend
that just your knowledge of him
just makes you feel good you feel better
in the world you know as a guy who
mostly grew up with kind of a big pack
of male friends i mean i feel strongest
and happiest and most secure in life
when i see something about one of my
friends doing well in life it just makes
me feel good if one of them dies and
unfortunately i'm getting to the age
where a number of them have died
then
you feel like all of a sudden like
goodness like there's a loss internally
right okay that's all sort of obvious
but what's interesting is that the grief
process itself
is about restructuring this map this map
think of it like a tripod it's got three
pieces space time and closeness when
someone dies
it's very confusing for the brain
because where are they in space well the
body is put someplace maybe it's
cremated maybe it's not
we have notions of a spirit and that
depends on one's orientation a soul or a
spirit okay or if you don't then you
don't then where do they go right and
then time when will you see them again
there's the never you'll never see them
again and the closeness component
remains and so there's an untethering of
this map and so there's been brain
imaging studies
beautiful work by
mary frances o'connor university of
arizona showing that if you look in the
brain and people that are in grief from
loss of a really strong attachment the
state of brain and body that gets
flipped on is a motivational state
it's
exactly the same circuitry in the brain
that one sees active if someone very
hungry is put just outside the wall of
some delicious food or if an animal that
really wants to mate
i guess mate with animals you call it
copulate they really want to copulate
with another animal is put just beyond
the wall of that animal but they can
smell them i mean these are highly
motivated desiring states so grief is a
motivated state to
bridge the distance in time and space
and yet it's impossible and so the
process of grief is a gradual waning of
that motivation
and a gradual shift of the memory of the
person into some concept whether or not
it's a soul whether or not it's just the
past whether or not it's their energy
and again it depends on what the
forebrain of that particular person
believes
shifts that concept of that person into
a place where the brain is comfortable
there's no more autonomic arousal
there's no motivation and we've all
experienced this if you've had a loss
and i've had a loss for instance where
my graduate advisor died and i adored
her and every once in a while her
daughter will call me from her cell
phone and she kept the same number on
that phone and the name and everything
so every once in a while it'll ring
barbara chapman and i'll reach for the
phone and then there's this moment where
i'm like oh goodness so anyway i'm going
on and on just to color this with
example but
when there's a breakup
it's exceedingly hard especially if the
person is young you know if you look at
suicides after breakups those are far
more common in younger people than they
are in older people why because the
relationship represents the whole future
they have no concept that they're they
know they're other people but it sort of
feels like the whole world is shutting
down
so
in
breakups what's happened is the person
is no longer available in time and space
this is why when someone breaks up you
literally have to let them go right you
know constant pursuing of them is out of
context is not healthy they have a name
for that it's called a stalker
don't do it um
but it's almost as if you have to
the brain has to think that the person
is gone in time and space this has
become much harder with social media
right because people can check up on
people they can hear from people in the
old days like when i was growing up you
just like took the phone off the hook or
you you diverted your attention
now we are constantly renewing that the
person is still there and so love and
the loss of love and the death grief are
virtually identical it's that
motivational state and this is why it's
so hard to not reach out to somebody
that you really miss and want back
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace